yeah when I saw the trailer I was like
Liam Neeson's married to January Jones
that's my boy
unknown so unknowns the story of Liam
Neeson who's married to January Jones
and Liam Neeson gets into a car wreck
goes back to January Jones and she's
like you're not my husband that guy's my
husband you're a weirdo so the whole
thing is is he crazy Z not crazy if he's
not crazy who's that other guy why is
she saying this who are these people
questions and spirit fingers
so most people I've talked to when they
see the trailer they think to themselves
oh it's taken to to be clear this is
nothing like taken not really taken was
a hardcore action-packed movie about a
guy going to get his daughter back who
happened to know fifty thousand ways to
kill people this movie's more of a
mystery it's like the mystery aspects of
24 without all the gunfire so instead of
24 you should call it you know - not
that it's a bad movie it's a really
interesting movie but the thing that
carries the movie is the intrigue of is
he crazy is he not I want answers and
the bummer is the trailer ruins the
movie for you in the trailer there was
one line that was spoken that I was like
oh okay that's what's going on one line
funny how that'll work marketing people
stopped that [ __ ] as for the movie the
movie is pretty much Liam Neeson making
phone calls talking with people
following a paper trail trying to find
out why he is not this guy that he
thinks he is who exists in the world
long story short Liam might be growing
crazy until people try to kill him and
then you're like oh is he not crazy
alright for some reason for a movie like
this there's not much to say about it
you watched the trailer you'd know the
movie it's exactly how it looks a couple
of really cool car chases a couple of
hitmen who get taken out a couple of
sweet deaths I can't say if you'd like
taken go see this movie cuz there's
nothing like taking like I said if it
wasn't for the intrigue of finding the
answers item in bored shitless and since
the trailer ruined the movie for me I
wasn't bored shitless I wasn't
entertained as hell this movie rides the
line of the middle the gray area it's
not revolutionary and new and it hasn't
been done a million times before I've
been done a few times before though how
about this watch the trailer if you
think he's seen this movie before you
have because when the movie wraps up and
you find out what's going on you're like
oh that's cool then you realize wait
I've seen this a few times before
damn it son of [ __ ] - unoriginal yeah
son of [ __ ] so I would say it's okay
but you're not gonna remember it in t
minus a day I'll give it one day but
then pop in taken which is a lot better
yet nothing like this sorry about the
mediocre movie guys I don't make the
movies I just say it how it is but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right
here to see more